okay  you are now in the hotel royal highways  antipatry in cadiz which are the  principal reasons uh that makes this  place the perfect location to train for  the world chess championship  uh there are many good reasons to  uh to be here uh first of all the  weather is absolutely beautiful not  um  too cold and  also not too hot  so it's just it's also perfect for  activities uh like sports like we've  been playing football we've been playing  uh paddle there's uh  there's there are beautiful gardens here  as well and also also good food so  it's really  a very  very good location to  to to prepare also it's important that  that the place in total is not too big  so that you can be concentrated on the  task